you know what I love most the thing
theme song ball ball ball ball best
theme song ever followed by this the
best intro ever ball ball ball ball the
thing I love the title - it's just so
it's the thing not really creepy alien
that looks like it's from Resident Evil
- no is just the thing so the thing
stars the dude from the warrior that guy
from dumb and Dumberer and scott
pilgrims girlfriends from there is just
a bunch of other people I don't know and
they go down to Antarctica because
there's this fine little do they know
that ship was holding the thing and
after that we have our monster movie
it's a monster movie but not your
run-of-the-mill monster movie that's
what I liked about it it has this anti
trust element going on because this
alien will kill someone and then
duplicate them now the alien looks like
them and no one else knows it so it's
one of those it could be any of us kind
of scenarios kind of like clue but
doesn't have that really hot made yeah I
was talking about the movie I've heard
some mixed feelings about the thing some
people like oh I grew up on the thing
and I loved it and this is gonna be crap
good thing is it's not a reboot of the
thing it's actually a prequel to the
original 1982 thing I think he came out
in 82 so don't worry it's not saying
your childhood favorite scary movie
didn't exist it's saying it did exist
and this is what happened before that
how rad so yes this takes place in like
the 80s which it kind of looks like it
does in some scenes and kind of doesn't
some people you're like yeah that is
early 80's hair you rock it man other
scenes you're like not that person looks
like they're in 2011 I myself I'm gonna
level with you guys I did see the thing
but I barely remember the thing mainly
because when I saw it I was kind of like
and I was a party I was hammered role
model so for nothing else I can tell you
how the thing stacks up as a standalone
movie and I can say it can be a
standalone movie if you've never seen
the original thing you can go into this
movie and be like oh it doesn't matter
now how do I like this movie I actually
liked it there is an element of me
that's like yeah I've seen movies like
this done before but the movie does what
it does really well I like the whole
element of you know the alien could be
any of us you can't trust anybody and
they play that up really well to a point
then after that it's just like yeah just
run from the big monster from Resident
Evil 2 and some parts in the movie the
CGI was really good other parts it
wasn't good at all in that those really
old horror movies have a leg up I think
because they had to have puppets and
makeup and when you can make that look
real it's actually an object that people
are looking at it's not CGI and that is
just a little more disturbing I think
weird thing is this thing duplicates
people and it seems to duplicate their
clothes too it shouldn't be able to do
that maybe he doesn't maybe I'm just
being
[ __ ] just seems like it duplicates
clothes so is it enjoyable yes it is I
will say it's a good time no alcohol
required God willing this movie still
around in Halloween is a perfect
Halloween movie take your friends to it
enjoy the [ __ ] out of it and in the
spirit of Halloween spirit if there's
time if I can do it if I get my hands on
the movie I will try to review the
original thing for you for Halloween now
to check Netflix if it's not Netflix let
me know so have you seen the original
movie the thing have you seen the new
thing which one do you like better
comment below let me know that's a
little bit of a strange thing - it's a
prequel to the thing that's also titled
the thing no plural or anything like a
lian's did you're not gonna make it the
things so you could get it from Netflix
and be like office sent me the thing I
didn't want the thing I wanted the thing
so you wanted the thing yeah and they
sent you the thing exactly but you got
the thing and you wanted the thing I
wanted the thing but I didn't want this
thing this is the wrong thing not that
thing no but a thing a thing the thing
it's not this thing wrong thing wrong
thing that is messed up it could be a
little confusing both of them sitting on
your blu-ray shelf or someone just
saying and as always if you liked what
you seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more balm all
best theme ever
you